okay so thank you thank you very much
for
today and welcome to the introductory
lecture on autism in this lecture we'll
focus particularly on how autism
expresses itself in the first three
years of life we are going to talk about
core features comorbid characteristics
we'll talk a little bit about broader
autism phenotype and spend some time
trying to understand what might be the
earliest signs of autism that are
present in babies way before behavioral
symptoms of autism come online autism is
a complex neurodevelopmental disorder it
affects in a profound way how children
interact with other people also produces
a series of very unusual behaviors
having to do with rigidities repetitive
motion and stereotyped interests it's
one of the most prevalent
neurodevelopmental disorders affecting
one in 68 children in general population
thus far we really don't have biological
markers or medical tests that can be
performed to determine whether the child
does or doesn't have autism for that
reason in order to diagnose the child we
have to perform a a close analysis of
the child's symptoms and behaviors it's
a very complex task as particularly in
young children Beeker because the
expression of autism is tremendously
heterogeneous some children with autism
have tremendous sensitivity around other
people and they are perturbed sometimes
even by proximity of others other
children are actually very interested in
interacting with other kids but they
lack basic knowledge of how to carry
these kind of interactions in a
successful manner some children with
autism will never develop speech others
are very talkative or verbose some
children have tremendous learning
difficulties whereas others
very bright and talented in many
different ways so the expression of
autism sort of varies along a number of
dimensions and and we are still probably
to identify other dimensions along which
our children differ what also
complicates diagnostic differentiations
early on is that it's a developmental
disorder what it means that the symptoms
of autism are expressing differently
depending on the child's age and
cognitive level so we can expect quite
different set of symptoms in an 18 month
er then in a five-year-old
then a sixteen year old and in someone
who is 25 so anytime we see a child for
a differential diagnosis early on we
need to be very mindful what can we
expect from the child from the
developmental standpoint of all kinds of
symptoms would be most diagnostic at the
given age what's important for our
discussion today is that autism starts
before the age of three and this is the
period developmental period we will be
focusing on during this talk so what are
the core characteristics of autism in a
young baby I mean in a toddler well I
think the first thing that we all notice
when we walk into the room and the child
may have autism is that they are not
really paying attention to things that
otherwise are tremendously important to
our children without social disability
and these two things are faces and
voices and actually limited attention to
faces and limited orienting to voice or
one's name is sort of one of the first
things that parents begin to notice when
they begin to worry about autism
another thing that's quite diagnostic
and specific to autism is a limited
drive to share experiences with others
if you ever interacted with a 12 month
or 14 month er you know they cannot do a
lot but they what can do is to pull you
into their world of experiences by
giving you something pointing something
showing you something for no other
reasons just for share
pleasure of joining in the same kind of
experience this is this kind of set of
behaviors is profoundly lacking in
journalism most are all our children
when we see them for differential
diagnosis or have delays in language and
this is not specific to autism a lot of
children have delays in language and
they are sometimes consequential
sometimes not what's very specific to
others and that our kids have major
difficulties in communicating with other
children non-verbally they are not using
their eyes they are not using their
facial expression and gestures to convey
meaning to other people in the absence
of speech and that affects how they
interact with the world in fact effects
quite profoundly what they learn from
the world as well at this site we are
beginning to see emergence of speech but
speech when it comes online it's often
stereotyped and not always fully
functional so sure not always here's the
words they have to communicate in an
adaptive way the speech is often
repetitive involves naming repetitive
naming of objects around or repeating
verbatim
question of phrases by other people
already in the second year of life we
are beginning to see emergence of
repetitive behaviors with strict
restrictive behaviors and unusual
movements they are not horribly
necessarily pronounced and sometimes
it's difficult for someone who is not
well trained in this population to
detect them but we are beginning to see
seeking or avoiding of certain sensory
stimuli not protecting ears from the
sounds or seeking spending objects
instead of playing with toys or the
track the child may turn it around and
start moving to flipping the wheels or
begin to show some unusual movement it
could be just saddle finger movements or
toe walking again not very pronounced
but present
so when does autism really emerge when
do we begin to sing behavioral symptoms
of autism that we can actually diagnose
this question has been in our minds for
decades and when I say our minds I mean
our researchers in the field of autism
and we ask this question in multiple
ways using a retrospective parental
reports and more recently by following
up babies who are at risk for developing
autism and it turns out that in the
first year of life is really hard to see
the kinds of symptoms that we would
expect in a toddler so we cannot sit
with a baby play with the baby and see
for instance poor eye contact or some
gaze aversion or these these behaviors
are really not coming online that early
by about 12 months we are beginning to
see delays in social communication in
use of gestures to communicate there
might be some withdrawal from from
enjoyment of social interactions and
parents see it and clinicians see it so
these behaviors are noticeable the only
thing is that they are not harbor
diagnostic the reason is that some
children who have these difficulties at
12 months actually grow out of them and
some children who have autism are
actually still okay around 12 months of
age so we are beginning to see emergence
of the symptoms but they are not yet
diagnostic the way we define the
symptoms or the way the things we are
looking at by 18 months however it's
only six months later we can reliably
diagnose about 40 to 50 percent of
children with autism and that proportion
increases dramatically afterwards so
what does autism might look like in the
first in the 18 months this is a time
when we say well if the child seems to
have symptoms the child probably has
autism so in order to answer this
question we did something something very
interesting
we pulled data from across several sites
in the you
Canada and we recruited infant siblings
of children with autism as you might
have heard due to genetic liability
these siblings add enhance the risk of
developing autism themselves so it's 700
children we had a lot of power to
actually ask a question what are the
unique combination of features that are
predictive of later diagnoses of autism
amongst younger siblings of children
with autism and we use a machine
learning algorithm something that we
call it's called classification and
regression tree approach which allowed
which in which we output it ratings of
the child's social and communicative
behaviors repetitive interests on 30
different items we allowed for all
possible combination of these features
to be entered into the model and then we
ask the algorithm to select those
features that are most predictive of
later outcome and we found something
really interesting if you look at this
little tree this is the little tree it
tells us which symptoms predict autism
and and what we found is that there's
others cup of groups here on the on the
your right which are sort of were put
into this category because they have
unusual eye contact they don't share or
engage others in their in their world or
activities and they also have very poor
communicative gestures and so there was
a group of children with autism and
these are the prototypical symptoms that
we'll be looking for at 18 months in if
we were to look for upper autism lack of
eye contact now sharing and up or
communicative gestures so that was great
on the others side however we also have
some kids with autism but they were
identified by a combination of different
features these kids have actually pretty
good eye contact that they were not that
bad in a face-to-face interaction what
they we're lacking however is the sort
of behaviors that then that that sort of
aim to engage other people's in their
activities and they were showing some
emergent repetitive behaviors
so why do we have why different features
predict different subgroups of kids with
autism well when we looked actually at
their verbal and nonverbal skills here
on the bottom we found that the children
who were showing this a typical
combination of features were actually
much higher functioning than those that
were showing a very prototypical
symptoms what does it mean this means
that our current diagnostic criteria may
be calibrated toward children with a
greater cognitive and language delays
and might be missing children who are
higher functioning especially at this
very very young age something to keep in
mind as clinicians well as we are
interacting with children in diagnostic
context the implication of this study is
that right now diagnostic tools and
screening tools work on the assumption
that one size fits all what we are
saying is that we might need to begin to
calibrate to increase the precision of a
diagnostic evaluation we may need to
calibrate the screening and diagnostic
procedures to specific sub phenotypes
within the spectrum one of the most
important things that we were concerned
when we started diagnosing children such
early ages is what is the stability of
the diagnosis at this age and what we
found and this is research in here at
the air in England other colleagues in
the u.s. that follow children for one
year two years five years 15 years is
the disability of early diagnosis is
quite high eighty to ninety percent of
children retained the diagnosis and
those who don't often have some residual
difficulties or some other related
related problems predictors of later
outcome when we see babies are very
young are pretty straightforward less
severe autism symptoms higher cognitive
skills which enable children to learn
faster and greater a rate of progress
over time what also helps children in
terms of overall outcome
is not to have comorbid disorders and
I'm going to talk about this ignore one
second
so I mentioned at some point a moment
ago I mentioned a special population of
children within within general
population which are younger siblings of
children with autism prevalence of
autism is about one in 68 children in
general population there are certain
subgroups of our population where the
prevalence of autism is much higher and
it's very important that as clinicians
we are aware of that because that might
sort of put a radar on anytime we see a
child with a specific syndrome or risk
factors that they might be then we need
to monitor these children also for
autism so one of the groups that's at
the greatest risk for developing autism
are younger siblings of kids with autism
the reason is genetics and as you are as
you might be aware genetic factors are
extremely powerful as etiologic factors
in autism with concordance rates for for
identical twins are being around 80% or
so so for siblings who are not identical
genetically the current concordance
rates are somewhat lower and depending
on the estimates they differ between one
in ten or one in five
so one in ten or one in five of younger
siblings of children with autism are
likely to develop the disorder
themselves now this number is moderated
by several other factors one of the
factor is how many are children with
autism there are already in the family
if there are two children with autism
already in the family there is a doubles
the risk for a younger child to develop
autism goes up to 30 40 % and now
they're very important factor is the sex
or gender of the younger sibling and you
can actually see it here are in this
graph where we have a comparison of
recurrence rates amongst boys and girls
as younger sips and you can see the boys
are much more likely to develop autism
than girls since the the the risk factor
go
about twice - it's twice as its High
boys an innocent girl there's one more
factor that's really fascinating and
there's a lot of work going on right now
trying to explain this is this gender
sex of the older sibling alright so if
the older sibling and this is these are
the bars right here if the older sibling
is a girl versus a boy then the
likelihood of the next child having
autism is much higher and it has to do
with we think it has to do with a
genetic load that girls need to carry in
order to reach affectation status in
autism so this is all new emerging all
sort of science and you probably will be
hearing more about that important to
think about it when speaking up with the
parents now the siblings as you often
hear you know we are dealing with a
spectrum light of the autism spectrum
which means that one end of the spectrum
we have autism and the other end of the
spectrum we have notice um so to speak
but there's everything in between so
when you look at this figure here on the
on the right you can see that it sort of
metaphorically that you know if we think
that there are children here who have
autism younger siblings who have autism
and then children who are developing
typically there is a group in the middle
and this is the group we call brother
autism phenotype these are the children
who are at risk for developing some
social difficulties not necessarily
meeting criteria for autism and they are
also at risk for developing other
difficulties already when they are as
young as 18 months or 24 months and we
see that there is a significant
proportion of younger siblings of
children with autism who have language
delays social difficulties emotional
regulation difficulties motor
difficulties and what's very important
to keep in mind that when these children
grow older during school age and
these children are twice as likely to
develop affective disorders anxiety ADHD
and a host of other difficulties so
again the reason why I'm bringing it up
is that we need to be very sensitive to
clinical needs of younger siblings of
children with autism who do not develop
autism themselves and if they are
symptoms present we should be actually
acting on them not worrying is that
autism is not autism it's irrelevant if
the child has played is facing
difficulties because of their
vulnerabilities we we need to intervene
it might in fact prevent some of the
later mental health disorders that we
see quite so frequently in this in this
population there are other groups that
are also at increased risk for autism
and one of them are preemies and as you
can see here on the top the risk for
autism increases as the gestational age
decreases which is very high risk for
autism in babies were born with
gestational age of 23 or 24 weeks it's
about 15% or so whereas the average for
the entire premium group is 7% or so
there's a number of genetic syndromes
where we see higher incidence of autism
including angleman syndrome Phelan
McDermid syndrome and more recently
congenital heart disease that that group
is still under investigation we don't
have a lot of really good studies
evaluating a prevalence of autism in
this group but current estimates are
sort of vary between maybe three maybe
maybe five percent or so I'm sure we'll
hear more about it in the near future
sex differences in autism right like
many other neurodevelopmental disorders
boys are more likely to develop autism
right if you read the sm5 the ratio
quoted there is four to one for boys one
girl if you look at more recent study
that actually are based on populations
they are not as there may be less bias
or more inclusive the ratio actually
goes a little higher goes goes down and
and the recent estimates are just three
to one
it's a very interesting question why
right why more boys why fewer girls when
we look at the severity of autism
symptoms between boys and girls in terms
of social difficulties the severity is
quite comparable between the groups
the girls however present themselves
somewhat differently because they have
typically fewer or not as intense
repetitive behaviors and also they tend
to be more introverted or have more
anxiety have more depression so they
tend to be a little quieter boys on the
other hand are very visible a lot of
Sirte peas and they also very
rambunctious very active and prone to
externalizing disorders including
behavioral problems so they are very
very very visible so in our field again
this is one of the areas to watch in the
coming years so we've been asking the
question you know what produces this
disparity between males and females one
sort of answers have to do with how we
diagnose the kids is the current
diagnosis sort of a social construction
or is our is the disparity due to
biological factors these two hypotheses
are these two groups of hypotheses are
not mutually exclusive they are probably
both and most certainly both at play so
let me tell you about the first one so
why do we have fewer girls than boys
very interesting several studies
evaluated severity of autism symptoms in
enlarged population of children in
England in the States and they they
found that boys and girls may have the
same severity of autism symptoms but
boys are more likely to receive a
diagnosis of autism in their
community right so there's some
something some kind of a diagnostic bias
that sort of prevents girls who are
clear clearly socially vulnerable from
receiving the diagnosis and being
treated appropriately and the idea is
that perhaps the diagnostic criteria
that we are operating within have been
created based on how others and
expresses in boys not how it expresses
in girls so for that reason it might
just select those who fit that that that
description survey it's a little
circular sort of way of designing
diagnostic criteria and using them and
this area again it's under investigation
we'll hear more about it in the very
near future another the biological
factors that have been proposed to
account for this disparity or
heterogeneity
for instance in terms of the geology
that there may be different factors on
both genetic and environmental that give
rise to autism in males and females the
hypothesis that has been more strongly
supported recently it's a hypothesis
which suggests that the ratio is due to
the fact that the girls may have some
kind of protective factors which are
preventing them from expressing symptoms
of autism unless they receive a major
genetic head so in other words they need
to have more typicality in terms of
genetics genetic or epigenetic factors
in order to reach affectation status we
don't know exactly what these protective
factors might be there are several
hypotheses one suggesting that there
might be some genetic x-linked factors
they're protecting the girls or there
may be some hormonal factors that also
art of lessening some of the edges or
around the social difficulties speaking
of protective factors we we did a study
not long ago where actually described
probably one of the first or if not the
first
evidence for potential protective factor
already in young babies this is a study
in which we use eye tracking technology
to evaluate how babies allocate
attention in response to a person who is
sort of interacting with them speaking
to them making eye contact there's some
toys you can see the example of a
screenshot from that video so then a
given point the child needs to make a
decision where to move their eyes and we
conducted a study in 6 9 and 12 month
old younger siblings of children with
autism and then we compared how high
risk and low risk
these are children without an older
sibling with autism perform on this task
in the red you see girls solid line
girls who are at high risk for autism in
black you see boys solid line boys who
are at low risk for autism and as you
can see something is really interesting
this is right red line sorry red run is
really really high both in terms of
overall attention to the task or to the
social scene and also in terms of
attention to the face of the speaker
it's a very interesting intriguing and
puzzling finding it might suggest that
younger sister of children with autism
very early on are employing perhaps a
compensatory strategies to try to get
some more out of social interactions try
to maybe remedy some of the
vulnerabilities vulnerabilities they
have and we are following up these
studies and we might have an answer what
it actually is and what it does but this
is the first illustration of a potential
a protective factor already infancy so
just to sum up our clinical implications
of the discussions we just had early
diagnosis is stable we have tools to
diagnose children in a reliable way we
need to be very careful how we do it
because we need to consider multiple
factors not just symptoms of autism but
also the child's language
family factors medical factors but when
we take it under consideration and we
are the trance presentation is
consistent with autism that diagnosis is
relatively stable there's no reason to
wait for anything it's there's a reason
to act and help families move towards
improving toward implementing
intervention services important to keep
in mind that not all toddlers are going
to be very prototypical the girls are
might might look a little different they
may look better they might become a
flashing some of their difficulties also
kids who are high-functioning might be
not quite showing the prototypical
symptoms that we expect at this age
given the high risk that we know it's
number of populations or subgroups
within our population has enhanced risk
for autism we have a mandate to actually
monitor these children and screen them
to make sure that we detect social
difficulties as soon as possible
and in terms of predictors of outcome we
don't have tremendously specific
measures but just on a very general
level having better cognitive skills
verbal skills and lesser severity better
progress or response to treatment within
the first month typically both well with
later outcomes
all right so we covered core symptoms of
autism and I wish this is where we could
end I wish this was all the problems
children with autism and their families
had it's not true unfortunately the
problem is that 70% of children with
autism has at least one comorbid
condition
and when I say commode with condition I
mean a diagnosis of ADHD affective
disorder anxiety schizophrenia many many
many other disorders their prevalence is
higher than in general population so in
some children or a lot of children
actually have more than one comorbid
disorder occurring what it tells us is
that the factors that are driving
psychopathology are overlapping to two
to a large extent but what happens is
that when a child with autism has a
Kimura birth disorder on top of it it
always it never bodes well for the
long-term outcomes these children
struggle more they have more
difficulties in adaptation social
functioning and they are less likely to
get more they may have trouble getting
an educational placement and that's
better matched with her with their
overall skills there's a high risk of
hospitalization suicidality and many
other problems for many years these kind
of problems were overshadowed by autism
and we typically did not diagnose or
comorbid disorders in children with
autism it was like oh you know his
autism so he's active oh you know he's
moody because he has autism dsm-5
changed that and right now a child with
autism can carry co-occurring conditions
as well what's important is that for us
as a clinician to also keep in mind that
we are not horribly well equipped to
differentiate or diagnose these
disorders in kids with autism because
there's so much
around of various symptoms and and they
and their and their manifestations
there's a lot of really really good work
happening right now in our field to
create better screening instruments for
anxiety for instance or ADHD for
children with autism and also to create
treatments that would be effective in
children with autism as and so as much
as they are effective in general
population so again something to think
about look for the more more more
information is coming why is it
important when we talk about toddlers
right because we're focusing on kids
under three we typically don't diagnose
anxiety ADHD affective disorders and
kids under three so why am i talking
about it well I am talking about it
because we know from extensive research
in general population that there are
certain precursors or signs of upcoming
difficulties internalizing externalizing
problems already in infancy and they are
conceptualized under the umbrella of
temperament which is sort of a
biological tendency to respond in
certain ways with regard to positive
affectivity joy or negative affectivity
such as fear and anger and also ability
to regulate emotions that arise in
response to internal or external
challenges what's interesting that these
patterns can be detected as early as six
months and they are relatively stable
over time and there might be self shaped
a little bit by experience but they are
relatively stable over time extensive
research in general population suggests
that a typical positive and negative
affectivity are related to later
internalizing and externalizing problems
so for us paying attention to how our
toddlers are doing in terms of their
regulation and emotional expressions in
response to real world challenges is
makes a lot of sense and I'll tell you
why right now so we have have waited
temperamental characteristics of
toddlers with autism this was probably
one of the largest studies of
temperament in young children autism the
strengths of this study was not only the
size but we also compared children with
autism with children with other
developmental delays I mean it's not a
big art to compare autism with typical
kids what we want to see how to autism
differ from children with developmental
delays and what we found was that
children with autism seem to display
less intensely positive emotion they
seem to experience less positive emotion
in response to normal to normative real
world environment they also seem to be
more negatively biased early on and they
have difficulties regulating emotions
that arise when when they're challenged
by new things or things they don't
necessarily like what was very very
interesting is that at this age severity
of these emotional difficulties was not
really associated with severity of
autism which suggests that they might be
totally different domains of functioning
that might arise maybe from different
different sources and then interact to
produce complex phenotypes later on we
follow this group of children when they
were four and there was very high
stability you can see these correlations
here in the 50s and 60s very high
stability within our group in terms of
how what were the temporal temperamental
vulnerabilities early on what was also
very important is that this early
emotional vulnerabilities contributed
later to severity of autism symptoms as
measure one or two years later so it's
an interesting example have two
different domains might interact and
produce complex reinforce each other and
sort of produce complex phenotypes
autism group so just to sum up we have
there are very good reasons why we
should be monitoring emotional
development and motion regulation in
children with autism it's not everything
that you see is part of autism it might
be part of a different set of risk
factors that are likely to produce
symptoms later on that will make the
lives of kids with autism less adaptive
and and lives of their families a little
bit more complicated because of the fact
that the various committees come online
at different ages right we might start
with some shyness early on ADHD anxiety
then we get into affective disorders and
so forth and so forth there is a need of
monitoring kids with autism continuously
for these problems it's not screening
them rating month and say yeah it's fine
no because there are problems that will
arise over time so screening kids for
these emotional difficulties throughout
their early childhood and early school
age is clinically indicated and we hope
that adequate or precise detection of
these problems and intervention will
help improve long-term outcomes in kids
with autism
all right we're gonna switch gears now
I'm putting my I'm taking off my
clinician hat and I'm putting on my
researcher hat because we are going to
talk about the developmental period that
sort of spans between birth and about 12
months or so and there are very few
symptoms that we can call symptoms of
autism during this time so we are
studying this time and in development
because we want to understand what's
really happening so is it true that
autism really doesn't start until the
second year of life or is it true that
there might be there are pathogenic
factors which are already unfolding but
they are unfolding on a level that it's
more difficult to capture with the naked
eye one of the line a line of research
in my lab is focused on trying to
understand why toddlers with autism have
such limited attention of ability to
select for processing people's faces
especially when the people are speaking
it's very important it's a core symptoms
about symptom about us and it's very
important because we we learn by
directing our attention toward important
sources of information in other words
attention gates learning if we are not
paying attention to people in their
faces we now try to decode what they
speak while attending to to their facial
features we're missing a tremendous
amount of information which is going to
affect not only how they develop
language but also how they develop
social expertise and Leo Kanner
this gentleman here in 1943 he already
noted that this kind of limited
attention to people's faces and voices
is present in autism very very early on
and so what we did is we created an
experimental paradigm which allowed us
to replicate what we see in real
in the lab and that replication is
important because then we can take it
apart we can manipulate experimentally
what children see what do they hear and
try to understand what's generating this
profound impairment in selective
attention to social targets and the
study involve a video I mentioned it
before but now I actually will give you
some more details in this video this
very wonderful young woman is speaking
to the camera trying to engage the
viewer using eye contact speech
occasionally she turns toward materials
on the table makes the sandwich
occasionally the toys start moving so
the child has to decide millisecond by
millisecond where to direct their
precious attentional resources and where
were the information is what they're
going to learn from the scene when we
take a group of typically developing
children and show them this video you
can see that they're behaving in a very
orchestrated way
hi again sweetie
how are you doing are you having fun you
look so cute today so as you can see all
children kind of converge when she's
making a sandwich they observe
goal-oriented action when she speaks
they monitor her face when something
happens perceptually salient they look
at her face when we repeated the study
with children who have autism and you
can see the graphs down within your in
red it is this group of children with
autism great developmental delay and
blue these are typically developing
children you can see that true with
autism are not completely lost they're
behaving quite well in many respects
however there's one situation in which
their behavior diverges from the other
groups this is a situation when she
looks at the camera and speaks trying to
engage the viewer in a sort of
using prototypical dyadic bits for
engagement in this situation they look
at lesser faces than children with
comparable cognitive skills as well as
typical controls since then we
replicated the study others other people
replicated the study we also extended
the study trying to understand what are
the factors that are separating children
the autism from typically or
developmentally delayed children and we
found that the factors that are
particularly important are the factors
that have to do with presence of speech
or combined presence of speech and eye
contact what we also did is we asked a
related question we know that
sensitivity to faces and speech is
present already in newborns when we show
a newborn a face like stimulus or we
play human speech they are capable of
orienting preferentially toward the
stimuli it's a very elementary orienting
mechanism subcortical II mediated
something that gives a newborn sort of a
leg up to know how to what where to find
the most important things they are going
to be very relevant to their survival so
what we did is we asked the following
question we see these deficits in
response to speech and eye contact at 18
months can we see them before behavioral
symptoms come online and we conducted a
study in younger siblings of children
with autism as we discussed about 20% of
them are likely to have autism another
30 40 maybe broader autism phenotype and
the remaining children will be
developing typically and we showed them
the same kind of tasks as we did to
children who already had autism and as
you can see this blue bar it's lower
then even that of the children who with
brother autism phenotype which suggests
that already at 6 months babies who are
later become symptomatic of autism they
already are showing selective difficulty
in
tending to faces especially faces that
tried to engage them in a face-to-face
interaction since then we replicated it
with a different set of stimuli and more
recently we actually replicated this
phenomenon in the face or in in context
of a face-to-face interaction we took a
very very precise and very detailed
measurement of the child's attention as
the child was interacting with the
person and what we found was that was at
one condition in which children who
later the robot isn't differed from
those who didn't and this was the
condition when the person sat in front
of the child and spoke not a condition
when she sang or play peek-a-boo it's
only when she spoke which was quite
remarkable because it really shows the
correspondence of what we see in real
world and what we see in the in the
laboratory conditions so what we do from
here right we are beginning to see
signals as early as six months in babies
who later develop autism these
attentional difficulties are likely to
be driven by a typical development of
brain networks that are involved in
prioritizing stimuli for processing
selecting certain visual auditory inputs
over others these systems developed very
early they develop even as early as
during pregnancy so what we are doing
now we are actually extending downward
our studies and focus on late prenatal
and early postnatal development what I
mean by that is that we are looking for
the roots of social and attentional
difficulties that we see at six months
already during the last trimester of
pregnancy and shortly after birth so how
do we do that we do that by conducting
brain imaging studies and what we are
using is is the resting state functional
connectivity approach the
is a very non-invasive non-demanding
and safe approach to learning about
brain function and brain development
what happens is that in a brain resting
state patterns are arise spontaneously
so we can image a child who is asleep
and still draw conclusions about how the
brain is wired to process specific kinds
of information we can evaluate networks
that are dedicated to processing visual
or auditory information we can evaluate
how the networks that involved are
involved in selection of stimuli for
processing function very very early on
the reason why this approach is likely
to be effective that we know that in
older individuals with autism some of
the networks that I just mentioned are
functioning are typically so what do we
know about current what do we know about
current state of network development
during the last trimester of pregnancy
it used to be that our researchers
thought that during the last three
months of pregnancy well we can see
emerging in the developing brain are
largely sensor networks these are
networks that are involved in in
modeling in processing a visual stimuli
auditory stimuli or for instance motor
function more recent studies suggest
that even before the babies are born
there are certain foundations that are
being laid for development of brain
areas that are involved in emotion
processing in processing of speech as
well as social stimuli as faces after
the babies are born in the neonatal
brains we are beginning to see the
network's they are very important for us
such as salience in network executive
control Network or default mode networks
already form an emergent become
functional
and we also know that the properties of
the networks are actually linked with
later development they are linked with
language cognition and emotional
development so what we are targeting
right now is something that may actually
tell us something about the mechanisms
that underlie early symptoms of autism
and we are tremendously excited about
this work because this is a truly a
groundbreaking work and we are sort of
at the forefront of the new research we
started we already started enrolling
families we have over 20 families
already following which is fantastic if
you hear of any family interested in
participating in our studies please
spread the word you know everything that
we do in our work everything that we do
in our clinics everything that we do in
our labs it's really designed toward one
purpose and serve my favorite video and
and the purpose is to make sure that
every child can live up to their
potential at their best and bring as
much joy as we can to their lives
oops so I wanted to thank people without
whom none of the work I I talked about
would be possible here the year we have
with a clinical team we are running a
clinic for infants and toddlers for at
risk for developmental disorders or
exhibiting symptoms of developmental
disorders
it's the yel toddler developmental
disabilities clinic and we also have a
research lab are called social and
affective neuroscience of autism program
our group is very interdisciplinary
brings experts in multiple areas and
these are people who are the most
amazing people to work with and I'm
truly honored to be able to do that for
so many years here at Yale so big shout
out to the entire team and thanks to the
families for really brings make it
everything that we do possible and our
funders who have to mention as well they
are tremendously important influential
in our life so thank you so much for
your attention and I'll be happy to take
some questions down
[Music]
you